[Music]  Luke reached out to my manager and I saw  how much he heard about this project  everybody who loves own is a fan of  Rupert on to work she was super sweet  obviously not scared of the camera  what's your name  Bogle he's creating this incredible  world when I thought my name on the  poster her Valyrian it got real I'm so  blessed to be having this experience  velarium 20 pg-13  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  well the city of a thousand plan  after centuries of peace and prosperity  an unknown force ought to destroy all we  have created  it was valerian and Laura lein you have  less than 10 hours to find the fresh  and eliminated  [Music]  history is on the March  [Music]  you  you